all right slugs we have quite a show for
you we are in goth again and we have the
hilarious krista stefano who used to be
my roommate here telling us all the
secrets so andy you're going to be on
the road where are you where are you
headed thanks little one
um i will be in
uh springfield missouri at the blue room
on february 4th and 5th uh also in
february i will be in british columbia
at the house of comedy i'm just going to
be in a lot of places i i'm going to be
in vegas i mean there's just i'm going
everywhere so check annie letterman.com
shows that's what she said
doesn't make sense there
you guys this weekend i'm coming to
raleigh north carolina i had to check
because i wasn't sure what state that
city is in and i'll be there february
3rd through 5th at goodnight's comedy
club and i'm going to
indianapolis philadelphia san diego
austin texas chicago and so much more
get tickets at estheronics.com but
raleigh i'll see you this weekend and
enjoy today
that's what she said
[Music]
welcome welcome
chris
hey chris i'm our first boy oh no rick
glassman but he's not like a real he's
not a bad guy wait is he the first guy
though when we've all been here together
like because there is like a vibe in the
room like there's a boy well it was the
same with jessica kirsten where we're
all like that a little bit like yeah
why because she's like more like manly
what were you saying that was a high
school thing
we all turned gay that day oh god yeah
jessica's good great and gay yes i love
jessica she's
so today the theme is goth goth 2.0
because originally it was going to be
goth with you the first time we did goth
but we we lost you so we we did it where
did i go
what do you mean you lost me
well you didn't come here i think
our first goth episode was supposed to
be dedicated to you right and somehow
i don't know what happened but it's
probably just the thing with you is like
they look goth but you just look like
mexican
you know like yeah
you just look like a fully like a
mexican school teacher i was going out
like at a christian school
i actually was going for mom goth
because i was like okay let's do adult
goth and i could go goth but
some something where i could still pick
my kids up from can i just tell you
adult goth is something that's going to
trigger esther it's steampunk
steampunk is scary right what's
what are you afraid you're going to get
like run over by
one of those unicycles or something
steampunk is like whenever you see like
hipster people with like goggles but the
goggles know it's not like not like ski
goggles it's like like a top hut with
goggles it's like um mad max style why
do they and this is like a look like a
hipster look yeah isn't that scary
i like to play a game sometimes like in
the neighborhood i grew up in it's very
very very gentrified now but like play a
game like take a picture of someone and
say hipster or history is this a is this
a person from history or are they just
[ __ ] somebody getting you know cashew
milk i do like
uh is it a hipster or a wizard they're
always like dressed like they're like
it's a type it's a silver lake look
silver-like look no but i like it i like
the top five and i gotta be honest like
the belt in my neck like it's very it's
kind of like i'm i don't know you feel
like you're in a hotel on the road yes i
hired a few ladies to come help uh
ladies you up on the um
yeah yeah no i feel like i'm with tim
dillon yeah i'm kind of disappointed
that i'm not seeing you in mesh right
now i know because i just happened i'm
just i'm disgusting what did you do i
saw you eat a muffin you crushed a
muffin oh that's that's what
wait you just ate it we walked in and
ate a muffin ate a muffin right away and
this morning i had a muffin and jazz
gonna be like you made a muffin what do
you mean by that no she wants to be a
fat piece of [ __ ] she wants you to be oh
yeah she wants to be disgusting that's
what i am i'm a chubby chaser
chubby chaser i love a good fat boy yeah
but jazzy she's not comfortable but not
like you still are like buff fat like i
want sloppy fat yeah the thing is that's
jasmine gets mad because like i you know
my body's like atrocious with no shirt
on but she's like but you're still
strong so she's like i don't i don't
like that you're still strong like in
the gym she wants to get fat and weak
yes doesn't she want you to be strong i
think i don't know i think she wants to
be left more than you yes i think she
gets married
jazzy looks like she could [ __ ] [ __ ] and
she's lefty so there's been a couple of
times where like you know she's throwing
a swing at me and if she was a righty i
would have gotten out of the way but she
caught me with a nice laugh you leaned
into it
[Laughter]
yeah anytime you see me boxing on my
instagram it's because she caught one of
my dms so i'm not just getting
prepared just genuinely curious i'm not
trying to be rude but do you wear a
shirt on during sex
i get completely naked actually even
taking my chain and uh bracelets like
everything like fully bought naked right
i feel like everything you're so like
the type of guy that every piece of
jewelry was given to you by someone very
special oh yeah yeah yeah it was like
this is like a 40 year old yeah no no
this is jasmine my
chain is my mother
um you know i used to have another chain
that was jasmine i had uh my father's
pinky ring like you know what i mean
like i've never actively bought jewelry
like if you anything in my life if you
were like anything i bought has been
bought on amazon or the gap like nothing
that i have that's nice and worth value
was ever bought by me it was only given
to me because i don't actually know what
i'm doing i have a question who is
shopping at the gap me and my mom i
think and anyone who buys yeezy hoodies
yes gap is coming back
i look at gap and i go i really feel
like there should be a gap in the mall
where this gap is because how is your
boring [ __ ] still being so i know and
the clothes jeans are great they're
they're great but it shrinks you can't
dry the gap close it will shrink in
medium but what if it's not that
it's shrinking and it's you eating it
i know it probably is it's hard to tell
since cloven i'm like what is this
that's really smart that you take your
jewelry off for sex because one time in
high school i was having sex and i was
wearing my grandfather's dog tags from
world war two
and guys that was on our [ __ ] ring
really wrong
it's like i'm gonna take these off
that's hilarious that's awesome i would
love to have my grandpa's dog
like stolen ballots i know my grandpa
was a nazi
i can tell by your neck i know i know
it's a german shepherd his dog
no you're a very italian no i thought
and then i asked so cause for for in the
neighborhood i grew up in uh it's called
ridgewood it's in like queens brooklyn
area and it was like a huge german
neighborhood when i was uh when my mom
was a kid like huge and as i grew up it
wasn't as german but there's even a
bakery there called um i forgot what the
name of the bakery is but that bakery
they provided uh
can i guess what it was called the gas
chamber they got chocolate
[Laughter]
yeah but they provided like the the
pastries and coffees for when the nazi
sold at madison square garden in like
1937 because before are they selling
tickets they sold out msg show up
they were like tom segura
i didn't know tom hated jews but you
know that he actually does the same
ticket sales no no they sold out the
garden before like the whole hitler
stuff but so anyway my whole life
growing up like there was like german
families that still live there and
they'd always come up to me you know if
i walk in the street and talk to me in
german and i'd always be like i'm not
like german i don't know what they're
saying and then i did ancestry.com and
it found out my ancestry was like 95
percent from germany and i was like holy
[ __ ] the de stefano my it was just like
my dad's you know uh dad's last name uh
my dad's last name but like he was
mostly german his mother was mostly
german my mother was like full who
[ __ ] the monkey to get your forehead
though i know
probably i don't know i know because i
do have a dandruff i've known chris so
long grace and i okay we used to do uh
shows at the open mics and danielle
rollins laugh lounge at the laughter
yeah chris would show up you were always
ripped you weren't as thick as you right
now but you were always ripped and he
was always wearing like a basketball
what no thick is fine this is good we
like thick now yeah he's a [ __ ] dad
yeah it doesn't matter his girlfriend's
trying to
it's like over for me yeah wait i have a
question does that cause you seem like
italian is very much your identity but
maybe i just project that like onto you
are you freaked out that it's like all a
lie no i think you're probably feeling
i'm just very new york i'm just so that
i think gets confused with
being italian it was a little like
shocking like you feel like you're lied
to your whole life i was like why did
everybody tell me i was always 100
italian or that we were italian and my
dad was like you know that's what i
thought and then we did like two
ancestry.com tests and both of them were
like
95 19. but what if ancestry.com is like
there's like a warehouse somewhere where
someone's like they're all getting
together like let's tell this person
they're this you know i just think this
the first time i ever saw you i thought
to myself that's a german whoa
there isn't a more german looking german
was your dad german what was your dad
well my a lot of my family live in
germany
well it was a little bit after knowing
that information it was a little scary
and i'm calm i'm i'm over it now it was
a little scary because all through high
school and college i love world war ii
like i said history part of history i'm
obsessed with but i always always always
were like besides the nazis
doing what they did with the holocaust
that's horrible but like other than that
like they had a point on why they were
going to war like i would always like
and i would always be like
justifying i was like their uniforms
were nice and hey i'd be mad too if if
you're scared
but then but then i was like wait chris
stop this you you don't like anything
about the nazis and i don't i hated what
they did with the holocaust and i do
believe that if i was alive back then i
probably would have been announced
because i lived in germany but it would
have been one of the nice nazis and not
done anything at all with those i would
have not ratted because my last name
would have been to stephanos so i can't
rat on the on on the concentration camps
but i wouldn't have participated and i
would have tried to get just say you go
into you go into someone's house and you
hear a creaking in the attic
oh my god okay
you go and you see a girl that looks a
lot like esther okay she's writing in a
journal she's masturbating right what do
you do do you i would go after her
i would say i'd say exactly this i'd say
are you jewish and you'd say yes and i'd
say you have a choice right now if you
have a muffin back there
if not you're dead
and you know those attic jews always had
muffins always jewish people are great
bakers there are like sex freaks german
people yes they're yeah oh yeah they
have the weirdest porn berlin has like
the best like sex clubs ever how do you
know are we going we might oh my gosh no
we're never going to a strip club we're
going straight straight to it do you
like do you like strip clubs because i
find that like men are i'm always asking
men like what's the good strip clubs and
they're like not that into them
yeah for me strip clubs i've been i've
been to them but i never
ever like really go to a strip club
willing i've probably been in strip club
um five times in my life maybe and i've
never had sex with a prostitute i've
never even thought about it i'm gonna
say something i've never thought about
getting a prostitute i think the guys
that don't like strip clubs that much
are the guys that like can pretty easily
get curls like yeah so you didn't have
to go
yeah i mean spend money maybe yeah
i could have gotten a girl to dance for
you like i remember going to a strip
club in tampa after a show in like 2014
2015 but it's just because they had good
like they had really good steak like it
was just the food and i like wasn't
interested
at all but i guess and i never thought
about it but i guess yeah because there
was a girl i would be like there's no
shake sandwiches when i'm dancing naked
okay we're not having anything well the
vegas ones they have like the 5 a.m
buffets like the breakfast buffets it's
so funny but isn't it if they have food
they can't show tits
no they they show their vagina
there's no alcohol yeah in the same
place yeah
yeah i've gone to the point now in the
age i don't know if maybe because i have
two girls but i've just like now it's
like i used to be like a full-on like i
just like even if you were like fake
boobs fake ass like you could just trick
me and i'd be like i [ __ ] love you
like i was just obsessed like you know
but now i'm like i'd actually really
would like if i was single like rather
like really get to know a girl and talk
to them and like literally like if you
came on too strong with sex i'd be like
no i'd be like i don't maybe because
i don't need it i'd be like i just wanna
i would like wanna like i would like
somebody who's like you know like smart
and like has done things with their life
like
but before i was just like if you have
like if you're literally like if you
just have like above a c cup i'm [ __ ]
in like you know like
your ex-girlfriends and they do not have
secrets
big bots of tattoos
it almost made me almost like i was
struggling with it a few months ago i
even talked to jasmine my girl and i was
like i feel like i'm gay like i
genuinely feel like i'm gay like i'm not
like and and she was like and she was
like no she was like i don't she was
like i don't think you're like she's
like i thought if you were gay or not
yeah but she was like but she was like
why do you think you're gay and i was
like because i don't like i don't know
like i don't find myself watching that
much porn anymore
i don't like i'm not like looking at
other women and being like oh my god
it'd be so great to have sex with i
don't care maybe you drained your balls
too much maybe you had it all you're a
good-looking white guy maybe each has
just had it all
um
i don't know i don't know if i've had it
at all
i think that all people like go through
ebbs and flows where because i know for
me sometimes i'm like super horny like
let's have sex all the time and then i
will talk about when she's on the
podcast
and then i'm like
no and then sometimes i'm like it's just
i'm the same way i'm like i'm just
completely turned off too i'm not even
yeah it could be like yeah it's like you
go it's like i always said i was just
bipolar or you could be gay
yeah
are you looking
i've seen carlos yeah carla come give us
a spin i like carlos yeah let's see this
outfit on carlos look at this
green lipstick
i like i like i like carlos
yeah look at that see look at this body
you know what you have you have like an
eight nineties body doesn't have like a
he's got a 90s body and and and and yeah
and when you take your hat off it's
[ __ ] wild dude yeah i love it because
because a lot of guys don't pull that
off but you do yeah
i actually think that's way hotter than
when you have a hobby it's so confident
it's almost like i don't give a [ __ ] my
dick is so huge i don't give a [ __ ] i
mean the dick thing but it feels like i
don't care that's the biggest thick
energy yeah you go to erawan like this i
think it's funny because everyone stares
at me and i'm always like nah dude uh
you would stand out in a crowd i think
it's great can we look at this cultural
appropriation if we cornrow your sides
we've got to
we need to have someone on the cornrow
i actually can't damn it annie
it's time to give your man a gift that
four million men worldwide trust which
is manscaped
the leaders in below the waist grooming
use our exclusive offer go to
manscape.com and use code trash for 20
off plus free shipping what i love about
manscaped is that they make the
lawnmower 4.0 it's their electric
trimmer that is designed to trim the
hair on loose skin and get this the
trimmer's advanced skin safe technology
reduces cuts and nicks on you know all
the delicate areas and it has a 4000k
led spotlight so you can shave anywhere
your heart desire on top of that you can
take it in the shower
with you because it's waterproof
um you can shave anything and everything
in the shower so you can say goodbye to
any left behind hair in the sink oh that
is such a gripe of mine please and
they'll sing still here in the sink i
know it's so wild there's something so
disgusting about those little straight
tiny hairs this package also includes
the weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer to whack all
of the worst of his weeds manscaped even
threw in two free gifts their shed
travel bag and anti-shaving boxer briefs
to keep his boys stored comfortably get
20 off and free shipping with the code
trash manscaped.com that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com and use
code trash
gift his cupid and arrow from manscaped
this valentine's day you guys let's talk
about it
magic spoon
it's my favorite cereal i had it for
dinner last night i had fruity with some
almond milk i just have a feeling that
that wasn't all you had for dinner but
it's cute that you're your dinner
appetizer why did we have to give up
cereal to in the first place because
it's actually filled with sugar and
preservatives really bad stuff for you
and it breaks like every law of every
diet that ever was except that's why we
have magic yeah because it's actually
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving and
it's keto friendly gluten-free grain
free soy free low-carb all of the things
build and you can build your own box
available flavors to build your very own
custom bundle that include cocoa
fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry cinnamon
cookies and cream and even maple waffle
i mean sometimes you're just really
craving that sugary cereal fun taste and
magic spoon is a way where i can have
that as a meal and actually be full from
the protein
actually not feel like a slob because i
just ate a bowl of sugar like it really
has made my life better
yeah i never thought i was going to be
able to drink cereal milk again at the
end but
you guys can go to magicspoon.com
tuesday and grab a custom bundle of
cereal and start your new year off right
and be sure to use our promo code
tuesday at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
literally refund your money no questions
asked so there's no reason not to try it
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
tuesday and use the code tuesday to save
five dollars off we thank you magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
would jazzy ever just let you have a gay
experience just to try it out i think
she would i got a little nervous once
like a year ago she was like going
giving me a [ __ ] and she started like
playing with my ass and i came like
immediately so i was a little bit like
whoa and she was even she was like damn
i don't know
no bobby has never let me and he's he's
the guy who's been with the most guys
right wait what so bobby has had sexual
experience with other men when he was
younger right right but like the
straightest dudes i've ever been with
they all love aspley yeah that's
good it feels good for me i can't
imagine it not feeling good for men have
you ever had a have you ever seen a guy
you want to hook up with
genuinely
no gen but i will say what i do what i
will say i think if if you ask me who i
am as a person sexually i would say i
fall in love with men have sex with
women that's what i'd say that's what
i'd say most likely i'm surprised
is that me
what the opposite
that you're playing i fall in love with
i i really i feel like you'll fall in
love with women and have sex with men
yeah
yeah it might be that i don't know i
think it's the opposite for you maybe
you fall in love with men you want to
have sex like she gets she gets nervous
about this stuff but i think i think any
sort of gay thing that's not the thing
that you
had done your whole life even like i
would say like if i was a lesbian and
then i would probably be so nervous
looking up with a guy
oh like you seem to get you don't think
you get a little nervous no i do i
totally would be nervous with a girl
yeah i think more than oh i don't yeah
well it almost feels like i think that
like women like it's hard it's easier
for a woman to have a gay experience and
then go back to yeah for sure it's once
a guy has a gay experience it's hard to
just once you feel because i think the
male ego it's kind of like well you're
gay which is fine but it's just kind of
like if you do that you're there you
can't come back but gen z is changing
that i feel like
nowadays like girls will date guys it's
actually
it's jen they say
but you know like i've heard young girls
will talk with their boyfriends about
like how to give blow jobs because
they're boyfriend i feel like i was the
first gen z because i've always been
attracted to dudes who
who like guys yeah can you i've always
liked to have boyfriends that are
straight that have never been attracted
to guys make out with my gay friends
that is a powerful yeah that i liked
interesting and i
have kyle's name tattooed on me because
i'm in love with her
i mean annie and i were roommates for
roommates
i think you paid rent for like three
months and i stayed there twice two
nights i was doing not aware of the
second day micro scene disgusted me
that's why he is who is he no my
christine mike racine is
one of the funniest
weirdest most honest strange truthfully
i mean he really is so weird
he there's autism in his family so i'm
not going to say there isn't a spectrum
situation with him yeah but he is he's
like the most shifty eyed person he's
farted
himself out of jobs before
dancing took him on a job interview with
him to give him a job on something and
he farted
in the elevator and then said did a do
you think hey guys did a ghost fart
[Laughter]
dude i hired him to move me out of one
of my apartments he broke something who
was this guy he broke something he broke
he broke a couch that i had um that you
know had like you could plug it in and
have like a recliner whatever he broke
that then he showed up but he showed up
to my apartment with just him and no
truck and i was like what are you doing
where's your truck and everything he's
like what you hired me like i thought
you and i were gonna do it i was like no
dude i hired a moving company
and he's like oh should i go get a
u-haul truck i was like yes what the
[ __ ] and then we did it and then he
literally broke a couch and we had to go
to um he left something back at uh we're
moving from staten island to brooklyn
there's a toll to pay a bridge and he
forgot something at my apartment in
brooklyn he goes oh [ __ ] i forgot this
chair and i was like well you have to
like go back and get it he goes yeah but
you're gonna have to pay for the tolls
and then i know he's just so crazy god
take it mike he okay
he first of all he started selling pasta
sauce at one point oh yeah it's actually
very good and it's it's so good so good
is he all available it is still event
we'll get we'll get a bottle of it
yeah um he's so funny he's so good but
when we live together he's just gross
like he's just something off and he will
do things like he'll pick his boogers
and then keep them and like what i'm
going to throw up they'll [ __ ] like that
he used to smell annie's
did he really well he would be like hey
you know annie's door isn't locked oh my
goodness
i used to do a joke about it because he
really the first year together he goes
he's like why do you lock your butt he
goes annie why do you lock your bedroom
door at night and i was like literally
because why
the fact that you even know i lock it is
why i love it
he's a [ __ ] sister we shared we
shared we had a railroad apartment so
like we were shared a wall and it was
just so frightening guys do that [ __ ] i
remember once benji came to my apartment
and i caught him going through my
laundry and he was taking pictures of my
dirty underwear like the crusty part
that's blackmailed
um racine once uh i had a knock at the
door and then under the door slid
a cartoon of two stick figures one was
with long hair yeah oh no no wait one
was him sitting there and then i was
blowing him and he was holding a gun to
my head
and he said you pointing to me
and
you laughed at that now it's like you
get arrested no every story i tell about
mike is so funny and then people are
like this is so troubling yeah like it's
abuse he said because i used to always
be like do not hit on me like do
whatever you do
and he'd be like one day he just went
annie you look beautiful and so i spit
in his face and then he went into his
room and he gathered all his crusty [ __ ]
rags and he threw them at me
and it was like the funniest it was so
funny i can't even explain to you how
funny it was like it was so disgusting
we were crying laughing then another
time i was just sitting there and he
came in and he just febreze my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's just like endless things and now
he's like married with a kid i know and
his wife is so
so cute and his wife is so beautiful and
smart and like a real person and she
loves mike this is bringing me to a
topic that i like i'm so obsessed with
and i get it it's just the way of the
world but like a guy that you're
explaining who's a comedian and a mover
like he has a kid the three of us don't
like i just feel like it's i'm so
jealous that i would like to be a dad
and i'm like i think we need to get
surrogates yeah you don't want to
actually give birth it's just so much
time
it's so much time it's a lot what do you
this is what bobby said about surrogacy
because i posed a question i was like
look like i got a heart condition like
i can't die i can't go under that but
you get pregnant so easily i i do it's
those hips
um but then he was just like honestly
kala i would have
no respect for you that's what he said
if you got pregnant no if i got a
surrogate oh okay he's like do the work
[ __ ] right i do think there's gotta be
like a guy that's
bonding with the kid though because the
pregnancy is like the whole bonding he's
more like i it would
he's like you would
i want to watch a baby come out of you
and i'm like that is so grotesque but
thank you for being honest no it's crazy
to see like
twice how fast were you trying to bang
her afterwards um immediately
no the first one it's funny but the
second like ob gym he had she she said
that to me she was like you can't like
even attempt to have sex with her for
like six weeks
she was just like i you know just don't
even i have a friend who had sex a week
out because her stitches were so itchy
and she couldn't get to them and she was
like can you just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
me yeah interesting
this time with with my first daughter
delilah
she they i was being talk don't look
don't look down don't look down and i
didn't i really really didn't and then
at the last second when she was coming
out you know because babies are born
with like long fingernails she hit
jasmine's vagina on the way out and
[ __ ] all of a sudden like i felt like
like fluid or something dripping onto my
sneaker so i looked down and it was just
full of blood and i was like what the
and i just saw it like guysing blood out
i was just trying to stay in yeah no no
she's just [ __ ] on the way out just
[ __ ] nicked her mom's vagina yeah and
then with my second daughter they were
like it was more of like you know not so
like scientific it was more like you
know it's your second baby dad you know
what to do whatever hold your hand and i
was like holding jasmine's hand i knew
like not to look down or whatever but
then
um it got to the point where for some
reason violet the the my seven month old
she had the umbilical cord wrapped
around her neck oh i had that too yeah
so it got like it went from so happy to
like [ __ ] like literally in 30
seconds she was like you hold your leg
now like i was like oh [ __ ] so then i
had no choice i was like in front of
jasmine's like vagina and i've never
seen like it got like this big where i
was like holy [ __ ]
like i couldn't believe like i could
look in and be like oh my god is that
your pancreas
you know like that was so but it was
great it's crazy to be like uh
a parent and have kids um it's very very
very difficult you're like
the level of exhaustion is like next
level how has it changed your like how
has it changed because you're a comedian
you're the dad to two girls like what's
different my time is like a lot more
valuable now it's like i just very very
comfortable being like i don't i can't
do this and if you want a reason i'll be
honest with you and then i'm just like
because i can't i can't i have to
justify time away from my kids now it's
like i'm not gonna just go like you
can't convince me that i i need to go
there for two weeks to like take a shot
at something it's like either it's
concrete gonna happen and there'll be
money in my account to make my
daughter's life better if not i'm gonna
go to my kids soccer practice like
my it's weird my career is like moving
forward faster than it was before i had
kids but i care about my career less
right because i care about my kids more
and then your career is doing better
because you're not stressing about it i
don't care about anything like anything
that happens i'm like what whatever like
yeah it's fine but has it changed you
and sorry has it changed you as a person
though like the way you like because you
know the classic thing like ben affleck
like i have daughters which is obviously
so cheesy like you should respect women
before you have daughters but but i am
curious like has it changed anything for
you it didn't in the beginning i'm be
honest with you with my youngest
daughter uh my oldest daughter delilah
she's six now is she six already six
yeah yeah oh my gosh she is so she's so
[ __ ] sassy i know i know she's great
she's like so much better than all ever
i had so much fun with her yeah yeah
then that when i did your practice oh my
gosh she says at six years old she's
like i'm gonna be like so much better
than you again and i'm like you will be
like you are you already are yes
nobody cares about me they're always
just like how come you don't post your
daughter on instagram anymore i'm like
because you creeps were asking what size
her feet were oh so that's why they're
so girl i mean i got a dm she was three
like hey what size shoe is she i want to
make shoes for her i love her feet i was
like get them
nobody's falling for that esther is the
only one
and the weird thing is she has the same
size feet as you can see there you go
probably but you know what it didn't in
the beginning it didn't not that i was
you know ever trying to disrespect women
but i was still like just a sex maniac
like just wanted to like when i was
there was a time where me and jazz were
co-parenting where i was like you know
want to have sex hook up like find women
that were like depressed like me and
like whatever wasn't thinking about how
is it gonna affect my daughter and then
it wasn't until delilah was like maybe
five when she started to she said to me
once when me and jazz were back together
she was like sometimes i don't like that
you and mommy argue or sometimes she was
like i feel like you and mommy make each
other sad and like things like that and
it was like oh [ __ ] like
the most subtle things that we do like
even if me and jazz are just like
sleeping back to back she notices that
and she's like why do you do that why
don't you have to explain her what a
double-headed dildo is yeah yeah i know
this is a different conversation i'm
like you see that thing that vibrates
that you thought was a toothbrush that's
why
that's not chocolate
but now but now but now so now i'm very
very very like okay you cannot you're
like an example for this kid like you
can't so it happens naturally um but you
know also it's like look you know like i
do
i do the best i can i mean you know hell
yeah we're gonna make [ __ ] mistakes
i'm also a comic on the road like i'm
eventually gonna just [ __ ] blow it so
i'll just be able to like tell her that
like hey i really tried i have the proof
that i tried but i also have the proof
that i [ __ ] up and i'm in prison
weirdly uh
both of those things he's wearing the
goth chain do you have any suggestions
for who you think would be good
surrogates for the three good surrogates
um that we i mean i guess you would want
which one is a woman with a a wide
birthing canal so and and big boobs no
truthfully i mean that's what they say
right like from uh that's why they say
men are attracted to women that's where
the attraction comes from big boobs and
and a big ass because what we're seeing
subconsciously is uh you know milk
right feed for the kids and somewhere to
lay my head like the kid's head and then
a wide birthing canal i thought you guys
like big tits because we
they can't run as fast that's true too
there's no going upstairs in this one
[ __ ] yeah i would say uh somebody good
who's a good woman that i would bridget
everett is someone i think she'd be a
good surrogate um um i think her i just
saw a billboard for her show coming over
here um i think um
who else would be good a nicole buyer
would be good or if you know what to
call big tits
not chelsea
why birthing canal she's a white burning
canal and and um and no i'm not saying
anything that's [ __ ] up i'm saying so
why the canal big boobs i'm i'm i'm
thinking
i'm thinking of her primarily yeah
the hips
we're not talking about you guys we
don't mean that she's a wide vagina we
mean her hips no i don't know if her
vagina is white or not i don't know who
would be a really [ __ ] good one
though i'm trying to think of somebody
with like big juicy boobs you've also
got to ensure that they're not going to
birth my baby and then take off with my
baby that's well that's the thing that i
don't know how a surrogate does what she
does because they're like this is a cute
one
nobody would cross you [ __ ]
also mine won't be cute so i'm good i
don't i think mine and bobby is a hit or
miss too no you guys both of you guys
are gonna have the cutest kid shut up
look at me man come on i'll look you in
your tears do you eyes
of course your kids are gonna be cute
yeah um i don't know if they'll grow up
you should just pick somebody that like
you know like doesn't like kids like
i don't know how much money do you have
to be given
who
give birth to a child that's like 100k
right you get 100k enough yeah yeah
i don't know yeah i
are you seriously considering it
i think we're all just at a place where
we're like in our 30s and
we were like maybe we want to have kids
but we don't want to you know being
pregnant can be so hard
it is it would be great for the for it
to be hard
the day the baby is there rather than
before the me like i don't want to have
to take like a [ __ ] year she was just
i mean you were there in the house when
we were living in l.a she was [ __ ]
miserable yeah for the last three months
and it's like it's you're like well
you're again
like trying to do comedies yeah i was
like what yeah like she like was like
what you're leaving it you're doing
watch you're going to the comedy season
she's stupid she's like rub my feet like
her organs are all displaced they're not
even where they're supposed to be
because they're all pushed up he knows
he looked inside he took a look i know
they were real i was crazy
i know you were really excited about
this sponsor esther i mean
just egg is one of our new sponsors i
have eaten
mostly plant-based for several years now
my parents are fully plant-based
just egg will change your life as a
person who's plant-based because it
tastes so good and it really adds so
many different kinds of foods to your
repertoire if you have it chest egg is a
cholesterol-free plant-based egg that
will give you the most decadent quiches
of your life the fluffiest scrambles and
the easiest egg sandwiches of all time
it has about the same protein as a
chicken egg and less saturated fat plus
just egg is packed with
cholesterol-lowering polyunsaturated fat
chicken eggs wish they were this healthy
i just don't know how i could
successfully do plant-based eating
without just egg because it tastes so
good and it really like
when you're craving that you it
it just it saves you i do like how it's
fluffy like how it comes out so it's
better than real eggs that's crazy you
have two options too because you you can
get the scramble in the bottle but you
you can also get the pre-packed also
it's cholesterol free it's better for
the planet
and it tastes delicious for me it's all
about taste so we know it's not about
saving the world
yeah and this doesn't contribute to the
industrial egg industry's mega polluting
impact on the world the new you we hope
wants a breakfast that does good and
actually tastes good listen up guys
oh i love that sound
oh yeah good and to think that you can
do that without drinking alcohol or a
soda dude and you're just you're getting
the the fun of being bad but it's water
can i tell you i crack one of these open
every night do you know how hot this
whole look is your whole get up look in
and i know with the
black liquid death can oh my god to
camera show everyone what you look like
what a badass
that was less hot
you guys were talking obviously about
liquid death why is this water called
liquid death ester
because it's death to plastic okay and
it will brutally murder your thirst i
like water that gets me more attention
is there something wrong with that i
don't think so
we love liquid death here we love
attention we love liquid death it's just
fun it looks like you're drinking a beer
but you're actually drinking water and
you guys plastic isn't actually
recyclable anymore and most plastic you
throw in a recycling bin actually just
gets sent to a landfill because it's not
profitable to recycle aluminum is
infinitely recyclable and actually
profitable for recycling facilities you
guys can get free shipping on all water
and merch oh my god i love their merch
at
liquiddeth.comtrash that's
liquiddeth.com
trash or just grab some at whole foods
or sprouts or 7-eleven honestly though
free shipping on all water is such a
good deal because it's it's expensive to
ship water liquid death.com trash have
them at your house for your next like
whenever you're having people over
they'll be like oh my god you're so chic
you're so weird and funny and cool it's
so good liquiddeth.com
will you ever forget we always get
well i'll never forget now i would have
i mean i know it's me but i would like
to i would have another child like i
would like to be father
not you know the thing is like every
time we have sex she gets pregnant so
she was like i have to like go on birth
control like i cannot do this again
because she was like you know so i think
she probably would we have to give it
some space though because you forget
like how hard it is to have like a
newborn baby like it's one it's so like
insane and we don't have like you know
you talk to some of our peers and
they're like oh just get the nightmares
to do it just get that i'm like
why aren't doing that yeah like jasmine
won't allow that like family will not
allow that they think that's like a
cop-out they're like no way she's like
i'm gonna [ __ ] do everything for this
kid i'm like yeah but you're angry all
the time because you're tired like we
let's just hire help and she's like no i
won't be a good mother if i if i don't
have the help if i don't do this myself
so i'm like all right
she's just angry at me all the time i
will be hiring
[Music]
i was just gonna say
you have a clip that went pretty viral
do you know what clip i'm talking about
tupperware yeah yeah
so
my fiance is
like a very normal guy okay he doesn't
like this show at all he doesn't like
comedy podcasts at all i like him he
hates this show
i do too but
he sent me that clip and i'm like oh my
god i know that guy
and ever since that clip my fiance who
like writes works with judd apatow he's
like a very respected normal guy who
went to harvard
he is
he brings up that clip like every day
really he says to me all the time i
thought i caught that yeah
there's something about it i caught that
yeah yeah her fiance is so not a fan
that one time he laughed at one of my
jokes and i bring that up to him every
day yeah
yeah if i was like you know like the
fact that he graduate if he graduated
from harvard and did like this show or
any podcast i'd be concerned it's like
those guys are so real it's like this is
for stupid people what we're doing like
this is not for grad ideally graduates
can i call him and could he meet you
your baby
what's his name dave hey oh dave okay
dave
look who's here what's up dave
what's up buddy
it is
what's going on nothing man i'm just
sitting here in a in a dog collar
why didn't you make one you made him
wear a goth thing too oh you
should oh my god it's cool
they wanted to put me in a fishnet
sweatshirt but i have tits
i tried explaining to him how obsessed
we are with that clip is there anything
you want to add or say i would say that
it's probably the thing
that gets said out loud in our house the
most
dave i have a question
yes danny do you are you sure is that
said more in your house or is dave make
me popcorn said more
that gets said a lot although she
doesn't esther will ask me oh yeah i'm
afraid of dave
is that a cry for help
you're afraid of me that i'm afraid of
you okay love you
hello bye bye i like dave no dave's a
good guy and here's the thing even when
he's not giving it to you you want him
you know what i mean he's such a gap
wait how jealous of you are you of chris
that chris comes into dave's life like
already the way he like lightened up
when he saw him and then was disgusted
when the phone turned to me it was i
don't know i kind of live for being
rejected by dave
i like dave dave's got good energy i
could see what no you don't want to have
dave's baby no i want to have dave's
baby
we were just talking you know carrying a
baby seems like a pain but there is a
thing where your pain tolerance just by
nature is a lot it's very difficult i
mean the most pain i've ever seen in a
person's face is when jasmine is giving
birth but you are like and that was you
look in the mirror
[Laughter]
such a dumb [ __ ] thing i did too i
left like an hour after my first
daughter was born to go um i had a a a
table read for the only show i've ever
gotten on like a scripted show i've ever
gotten on and i did i did a table read
for it and because she took a nap so i
was like oh i can leave and then she
woke up i was like where's the father of
my child you know like my mom was like
he went to go do a table
which they could have definitely had
someone else do yeah dude i was such an
unimportant part of the show yeah did we
talk about the whole um the duck sauce
thing on here no no didn't she get in
trouble for
th the duck sauce on netflix i got fired
from the
what happened i don't know any of this
when so what happened was i was hosting
a show for netflix called the ultimate
beastmaster and they that's that was
just it was like american ninja warrior
i can't believe they didn't ask you to
be
the ultimate peacemaster yeah it it and
so it was like this game show
competition it was like they went
through like this obstacle course and
you know like it was like um like
american ninja warrior but you know
netflix version so i was the host of the
every country had a team so i was the
host of team usa and they told me they
were like make jokes like you can be
silly whatever like just go crazy so i
was like okay and this was like in 2000
this was like we filmed this show in
maybe may or june of 2016. so in
november of 2016 you know trump was
going to get elected and everything was
going to change but that show came out
in december of 2016. so it was like it
had been filmed before trump but it was
aaron post trump so this is a big
problem
the world had changed so the jokes that
i got so
people wearing uproar at me because a
member of the chinese team his name was
bin fung he was awesome and when you
fell off the when he got eliminated and
fell into the water they called it the
beast blood and then one time the kid
bin fung fell and i said there goes bin
fung into the duck sauce
and
you know like and it was fine and then
when that came out they were like you
racist piece of [ __ ]
and then and then at that time team
india was really good and one of the the
team indian host uh co-host was a uh
indian supermodel like a from the
country of india's supermodel and so
they the producers would tell me go in
there and be like hey if you know team
usa loses the team if team usa beats
team india in this head-to-head
competition like we gotta you know
netflix and chill because on netflix
whatever and i was just at that point
like an absolute puppet i had no
experience at all i was like whatever
they tell me in here i'm just gonna say
i'm like you know being like please like
me like me i had no confidence in my
abilities at all i was just like a
[ __ ] puppy yeah i told him so i'd be
like netflix and chill netflix and chill
then you know obviously comes out this
everyone i'm a sexist um me too people
call me a rapist and i'm like so i
called this girl
from india and i said it was at any
moment like i didn't apologize because i
was like i want to be careful my words
because i was like i don't believe i did
anything wrong it's like an outcry like
psychos on the internet and i said at
any moment
did you feel like i made you
uncomfortable at all and she was like
absolutely not she was like you're
what's happening in your country right
now is an american issue she was like
you never really had any real problems
and now you have this guy that nobody
likes and you're you're [ __ ] making
[ __ ] up she's like you know there's
packs of men that go around and rape
women in my village she was like do you
remember the time when you got when i
got she got like moving there she was
like
yeah so she was like don't listen she
was like that's just don't respond to
them i was like can you send out a tweet
no one touches me
yeah we throw you in as a distraction
yeah yeah so that was crazy wow yeah no
it isn't interesting but it makes me not
want to do any tv ever like i get like
viscerally like i feel in pain when
people ask me what's funny is that it
obviously aired right yeah so everybody
from the day that it was filmed up until
the day that it aired thought that it
was oh an okay thing
and then they see and then they see the
reaction and then they blame you yeah
it's disgusting but we said [ __ ] up
[ __ ] on girl code oh my god i mean we we
used to do the show on empty vehicle
girl code and you did the guy code too
but right it was and we did guy code
versus girl code where they would
literally give us like topics like
should women get paid the same and they
go all right chris you say no
no women you don't work as hard like it
was like great
man have bigger brains
and everyone that we worked with was
great like it was like such a fun thing
but it was like but when i did realize
like maybe this will pose a problem at
some point oh sure was when i i came
outside from doing something at the in
times square where the mtv studios is
and i came out and i was talking to
these cops and they were like what were
you filming and i told them it was girl
they're like we love guy co that's how
we learn everything like how to treat
and i was like what these cops are
running around yeah
having learned like girls just actually
learn from it no i know it's like a
comedy show it was like parody almost it
was a [ __ ] comedy show but no there's
so many things like that where like you
look back and you're like oh i'm getting
like even with television like some of
the [ __ ] i've said on podcasts or
tweeted that's like literally just jokes
they're like not okay now it's like i
don't even want to deal with it like
i've been doing this thing called
chrissy day times where i go on daytime
talk shows and just bomb on purpose oh
my god i love you is that really on
purpose i swear to god i swear to god
are you kidding that sounds amazing well
it didn't start out on purpose
with whitney first one with whitney and
then i did just did nick cannon what was
the joke um yeah i saw that cannonball
but um what uh what was the joke that
bombed on whitney's again because i
remember seeing it i'm forgetting what
it was it was because you were talking
podcasting which they're not allowed to
do it so it's like so even on like the
the like view type shows and stuff like
you're there's just no well like because
whitney's like you know like one of us
right like a real comic book but some of
the other people on the panel like the
jokes that they were getting laughs out
like i wanted to throw up i was like
these jokes suck like what are you a
[ __ ] politician i was like i'm not
doing this [ __ ] i'm gonna be who i am
and of course my jokes were bombing for
that crowd like i didn't even get paid
they were like leave yeah they're like
yeah like it was crazy but i was like
you know what i might the guy that
produced my podcast homeless pimp when i
showed him and he was like dude we have
to put this like you have to put this on
the internet like this is like your fans
will love this so i was like you know
what so then we started splicing up and
it got all these views and then when i
got booked on the nick cannon show they
said um they said uh listen we saw your
wendy williams thing they were like it's
it's funny it's great you know all this
it's so great and different blah blah
blah but the nick cannon show is live so
you can't do those things you're gonna
have to stay within the lanes and i was
like absolutely i'll do it and then as
soon as that show started i started
going [ __ ] bananas well i can't it's
almost insulting when they ask us to do
that because that's not what our job is
it's like our job is to like disrupt
things to be like yeah i was like i'm
not doing knock knock jokes and trying
to get claps you're like me where it's
like we just said the funny thing is as
fast as possible like people will be
like you're interrupting you're doing
this or you said something i'm like i
literally it's just i have to say it as
fast as i can think of it and then edit
it out like if it's not good afterwards
yeah i never care if anyone edits
anything out but i can't like self-edit
that's not we blur your face she said to
edit anything else
yeah she doesn't care i know obviously i
can't self-edit my face
i like that look on you though you look
like somebody yeah i am who is it she
almost like does she look like natalie
portman or something maybe or is it just
scarlett johansson in a movie that i
maybe it's that but dude
with hepatitis c
that'd be a good movie but it's just
like a documentary about how college
games they're like this movie's about
scholarship hence with appetizers i
hired letterman
[Laughter]
six people in the world that look
exactly like you really that's
interesting and it says the percent the
the
um
percentage that you the likelihood that
you'll run into at least one of them is
ten percent well i can see like like we
obviously i'm german too like we
obviously have like
relatives in common somewhere yes i can
see your my face in your face a little
bit you could be a sibling of mine what
does her look alike whitney has a woman
that looks like oh yeah that's so great
and she comments yeah yeah and she has
this woman come out and she came to her
party and it was so confusing really
you were there i didn't see her i would
love what if you're in person just had
her there to talk to you
that's the only whitney i know is the
look-alike you've never met the woman
that's so something she would do to me
that's crazy wow that's not her sister
or anything no she's not related to her
at all that actually is a little
it's a little like gives you chills yeah
it's [ __ ] up because because you want
because whitney's had plastic surgery so
you wonder if that's oh if she went in
and got it yeah or if she brought a
picture of that girl yeah is that the
that's the girl's face she stole
that's so funny she just skinned it off
of her yeah yeah the weirdest thing that
i always think about though when we talk
about how you look like scarlett
johansson is that
you're a twin i don't have star quality
money no
no this is weird annie is a twin
scarlett is a twin you also look like
those twins on big brother why do twins
have a similar oh that's interesting
like right well you look up scarlett
johansson's twin brother there's has a
twin yeah and here there's a picture one
time
he looks also like famous twins from big
brother it's weird all the twins look
alike from b they're all not like each
other but like other twins wow my
brother my older brother once sent me a
text and it was a picture of my twin
brother he goes who is this i go it's
max where do you get those glasses
there's and it was she goes no it's
scarlett johansson's from brother
there's a child with glasses that looks
like my brother
god what an incestuous world we live in
i love it that is weird i people used to
say that i look like macaulay culkin
like when i was a little when i was a
child
you have a childhood picture that's
online you think um
i don't if it is it's like deep in my
instagram yeah um but to the point where
my mom told me when i was like you know
like a little boy like people with
people uh multiple times came up with
like is that mcallen hawking and it
wasn't obviously but we have the same
birthday august 26th so i was like
that's weird i thought you were gonna do
a joke about when you were a kid your
mom left you home alone
i was abandoned
your mom never left your side no never
not at all chris you look just like the
german guy from gladiators you are
german like that's why i thought you
were german yeah yeah i look i i guess i
can see
that's a look yeah i don't i mean i look
like if you had a woman's body
let's just say you look like you have a
wide birthing canal
do you have girl hips yeah yeah i have a
size 38 waist like just fat
thick waist is okay but i want to know
if you have hips what does that mean
your hips are bigger than my bust yes if
your hips uh jut out past your waist are
thicker than your waist
uh
i don't i don't think stand up let's see
oh i'm sorry don't worry esther's a
lesbian well you have a big butt but you
don't have girl hips yeah yeah yeah yeah
it makes me sad do you know what is
making me so excited right now is that
if this were three guy hosts and you
were the girl and you were our guest and
we were like nitpicking your body and
making you stand up and show us your ass
yeah how [ __ ] up is that well i have
come to the conclusion that me
personally and i think there's a lot of
guys out there that feel the same i at
this point i do not get i if i'm going
to get in shape it is for other guys it
is so other guys will look at me and be
like thank you something strong because
women
seem not to care we don't yeah we don't
watch you know thank you so much for
saying that yeah yeah
yeah i guess i believe that i genuinely
do yeah i will tell you something if i'm
working out i can tell you one thing
it's not for todd
danny i got it i'm on the same wall i
have never worked out a minute of my
life for bobby yeah a minute not a
[ __ ] minute you know what it is
[Laughter]
have you guys ever hooked up or anything
or i think the most we've done is
probably give hickeys to each other yeah
um and then maybe like a soft peck yeah
is there a world where it happens it's
very it's an emotional connection
you're really going to kick her [ __ ]
out of your mouth
come on
look i keep pitching the sleepover
episode nobody nobody's getting the
strip club i mean we've gone to
different states and discussed going to
strip clubs it's never happening it's
never happened
have you ever you never went down on a
girl did you or you did yeah no i got
fingered by a girl once and i felt like
she fingered homophobia yeah
i was like when she was at like her
knuckles were and i was like this feels
strong none of you guys have really
eaten gotten down on a girl at all i
just when it comes down to moments i
always get a sore throat
from the hpv yeah
you have only thrown hpv yeah i have it
on my tonsils
if you got a tracheotomy they'd be like
oh my god look at those there's warts
all over that for me
you really can get a warty throat no i
know that because of [ __ ] katherine
zeta jones and michael
that was one of the dirtiest press
releases i've ever seen where michael
douglas said he got throat cancer but it
was because he ate catherine's age
that's right
that's hot it's the funniest it's just
like so funny and nobody is like
revealing that type of information in
hollywood yeah but i think that that's
very um practical and you know usable
information because you and you can get
a wordy throat that's a fact now all the
kids get that gardasil vaccine so
they're like it's like curable that's
that's right you can prevent well no no
it doesn't prevent all strains of it
does it just the the the one that the
ones that cause cervical cancer yeah but
you can deal with a wart i just get you
don't want to get cancer right yeah
because the wordy one is not the
cancerous one you're like i don't want
to offend you are people worried are
people worrying about cancer
getting sick and dying or are they
worried about like looking like they
have an std probably looking like an std
brother just like scarlett johansson and
we both have general words look at the
same place
i i'm telling myself it's a skin tag
you could just get it burned off you
guys haven't had one burned off my whole
life when i was young like 18. oh never
they never came back
remember how worried i was so worried
about stds when i was in my 20s yeah
and it's just now i'm like i don't have
any of like a big one like i got
chlamydia but i never got like herpes or
aids or anything like sirius or ghana no
i never got gonorrhea just chlamydia and
one wart
i just learned something recently is
that
what do you think the clap is the clap i
believe is gonorrhea
i don't know that's why i i got it
confused it's a c and a c but he's right
he's gone
can you check carlos
carlos
with his outfit doesn't he look like i
know he's just going to keep that on all
day
carlos made was making plans for tonight
with that outfit carlos are you gay
i'm not gay no i'm not okay okay there
was a pause that we weren't sure about
yeah but i would have answered the same
one two second pause and then no you
guys have similar i i would say you're a
little bit effeminate both of you
yeah i thought i i i wouldn't i wouldn't
have been shocked if he said he was gay
he's also aware of possibly one of the
guys
and may i just say carlos that you've
never looked hotter to me you call hr
after this but like i genuinely think
this is the hottest you've ever looked
right now yes the shirt
it's something about not wearing the hat
and then the shirt but the way he stands
up so straight like he doesn't give a
[ __ ] is really doing you know what i got
good posture i'm gonna add it to my you
know what it is it's that he doesn't
like find you attractive yes i think
that's it he can't get a boner when you
poke him that's crazy the posture is
from military school too i know this is
a new part of you that i know carlos
went to military school did you go
no
briefly i never went to military school
just briefly i feel like you'd get
recruited to one jason looks like when i
went to munich for the oktoberfest in
germany there was a german soldier that
was there like this guy like his
off-duty i guess whatever drinking at a
bar and he spoke english and he just
started like hitting my chest and back
he was like you should you should be a
surgeon
and i was i was i was like well were you
tickled by it i was like oh it's fun i
was like you guys starting up the old
old guy
don't ask dude where are we marching
okay so in the 1500s the word clappier
or clapier was used for referring to a
rabbit's nest no but it's because people
were [ __ ] like bunny rabbits okay ah
okay and these jackrabbits really do
[ __ ] all the time that's a real thing
are you yelling at me i'm a hug
like you [ __ ] you you know what's
something i just don't you know what
knocked up comes from
knocked up this is interesting because
like now you can cancel anything it's
like knocked up like one of the most
iconic movies of all time it's like if
somebody finds out where it came from
it'd be like we have we have to put his
[ __ ] head on a spike but knocked up
what it is is is enslave
times if they would if you were uh uh uh
at the slave market if you were a female
slave and you were pregnant your price
was knocked up so that's where the term
i got knocked up because it's your price
is up as a slave shot why was your price
up if you had a baby in you because they
got two you got two for the you got two
humans for the price of one so your
price got a little knocked up or or it
was like it wouldn't be it would be like
you know whatever a few more dollars or
something like that
i learned that at the charleston slave
market great tour
and honestly what's so wild about that
is now in our country if you're knocked
up you you're you go down nobody yeah
yeah you know well that's like too even
now like you know again just loving
history it's like back in the day it was
like the rich were fat and the poor were
skinny but now i feel like the rich are
fat and the poor are skinny and i'm just
like this is like this whole [ __ ]
world where you're like when you read
enough history you're like oh [ __ ] we're
like going like is that why you're
gaining weight as you gain success i'm
yeah you're trying to put it back right
yeah
yeah wait but the richer fat is still a
very asian thing like we love
especially chinese people living in the
philippines like they love that baby
means rich's family
i just there's something in me is
i'm feeling called upon this to like
bring chris to the skokie holocaust
museum i don't know why but just how
german you look yeah i feel like you
should just come there and just like you
can role play anne frank
just have a good time i know when i went
to dacao concentration camp when i was
in germany just like you know they give
like a tour and the tour guide he was
actually filipino guy but he was a
german tour guide he was like yeah he
was like you he's like you have like a
pretty striking german look he was like
it makes me a little uncomfortable but
he was saying it in a silly way but
that's because i was doing pull-ups off
the top of the gasket
you're opposing like yeah i was like
hell yeah i was like home
i i i did an open mic there
you started an ambush show
an ambush chamber show in the in the
showers yeah to counter all of the
holocaust talk
um i'd like to present something more
wholesome
information and that is did you guys
know that
beetles perform oral sex on to each
other to entice
the female for copulation ringo and
george harrison
so wait are you saying beetles like
we'll have will like blow each other
blow but the male will um
perform fellatio on the on the woman oh
okay to entice her it's like basically
he's giving her foreplay and before he
has sex with her yeah but i feel like
humans do that too right i know but then
this idea that you know that's such a
human thing or such like a high primate
thing it's actually might not be true
not true at all yeah i know they say the
same thing about like monogamy too like
all monogamy's like a human contract but
there's a lot of animals i think that
are like monotonous totally lobsters
yeah
yeah some penguin i think yeah yeah
that's pretty interesting
isn't that so funny how hard they try to
make monogamy a thing yeah or not a
thing
well
maybe i'm looking at the wrong direction
i'm like are you following me on twitter
no it is like i mean when sex and dawn
when sex at dawn came out it was just
like what's sex at dawn it's a book
about how
no like humans shouldn't be monogamous
oh yeah and it's about
you've got to stop pretending like you
don't know about this book
yeah yeah i have a signed copy but i
just felt like couples that like you
know all of a sudden they start reading
sex at dawn
it's signed by the girl's tit print
and you know and then also they're
reading it and then it always ends up
like their marriage is over
i i've been in a poly relationship and
that lasted for years um
there is i think there are people out
there who really successfully do it like
i have a girlfriend of mine who's been
in a relationship with two other women
for years they're married well they're
married and they have a girlfriend and
when i look at their lives i'm like [ __ ]
this is the life that i want it's just
so fun i think maybe it looks more fun
because they're all women
okay they're all women well i i there's
a audience
there's two audience members that i've
seen a bunch they've been hanging out i
don't know if you've seen them too but
they're like they look like they read
like a lesbian couple but i'm doing my
crowd work with them and they're like no
we have a third but i don't know why the
third number comes but i see them all
the time
i'll take a picture of the next time i
bet you see them but it's funny so maybe
there's one for each of us
yeah look if it were up to me i'd have
nine husbands and that's a fact yeah i
just feel like i've had boyfriends that
have already been in open relationships
and what i gather from them wanting to
be in a relationship is they literally
want to [ __ ] like
all day long i'd have i'd have seven
husbands sleepy mopeds
that i want i think i'd probably only
have like one or two for sex all of the
other things are more like um
everyday life stuff like he does the
plumbing this guy's good at this this
guy
is what i'm saying like having sex with
that many men is exhausting
one or two is enough there was a time
like a year ago where jasmine was like
listen i know you like go on the road or
whatever you're a good dad she's like
you can do whatever you want like as
long as you don't bring home any
problems and no other babies and no
disease or anything you can do whatever
you want just leave that [ __ ] in
whatever city you're in and we won't and
it's like unspoken how fast did you [ __ ]
this up i swear to god since she told me
that it's almost like she released me
mentally from the prison i haven't even
attempted
to do anything with any woman on my
nothing zero
yeah yeah that's amazing because maybe
it is it's that feeling trapped part
that's
it becomes a temptation when it's
something that's forbidden right if it's
something that's not forbidden then you
reframe it in your head as something
that oh i can do this any time anyway
this is i'm sorry this is just exactly
how my relationship with cinnamon rolls
works
like
once i've said like you can have it
whenever you want it it's like not a big
intuitive eating and total banging yeah
yeah intuitive banging i had a guy tell
me that once about his girlfriend where
he said his girlfriend gave him like
full freedom and he like didn't want it
yeah i just don't i don't even it's just
like i i don't know i'm like i'll just
know i mean todd has freedom the girls
don't
[Laughter]
no i love what dog gets it it's like my
favorite thing yeah dude i love it when
you think you guys have been together a
long time now right uh yes since like
right before the pandemic knot oh wow so
that's good you made it through most of
the pandemic and he's not a [ __ ]
comic except he did used to do open mics
and people will come up and be like
still doing mics and i'm like we need to
no one that thinks you didn't open mics
yeah they can't be a part of this you
gotta be gone well i told him when we
first were dating i was like if you want
to meet my friends you have to i have to
never meet yours sorry i keep touching
your knee jazzy it's not on purpose i
don't care no it's okay i've already
came to carlos
i know leaving this room until the black
lipstick goes on i think yeah
i put it on perfectly
do you want to put it on oh you're going
in the bottom first that's a new
technique
this is actually amazing because you're
doing it so differently like the fact
that you're staying on your lips of like
because i would
dab it yeah yeah
oh yeah and you might want to follow her
too make them fuller the top
yeah i when people especially in new
york chris when they get like offended
when they're making jokes i want to
scream you know i'm like it's just so
unacceptable do i get in the lip too
not too much
but just enough that it that's perfect
because it'll yeah
honestly it looks great you think so
yeah thank you it makes your eyes
honestly we knew you were gonna look
good goth we knew it yeah i like it have
you ever like enjoyed a little eyeliner
you know boys always like there's
there's a halloween costume involving
some sort of makeup i don't know that i
enjoyed it what i will say is that the
times that we used to do guy coat and
girl couldn't get like full makeup i
never would take a wipe i would keep it
on for this yeah yeah yeah you're like
okay
i would stay i would stay with the
makeup on for you maybe like why is
there make who did you [ __ ] last night
like it's actually my own makeup it's me
oh yeah oh my god when they would do
that chris thank you so much thank you
like fulfilling our goth fantasy of
course
i wish i i mean yeah i guess i'm not the
most goth guy but you know yeah that was
it yeah we got we got what we needed we
got it right here we needed yeah yeah no
it's it's good happy to be goth i feel
good here i will keep this on i think
i'm definitely gonna get back in the
uber with this yeah oh i dare you 100
just do it don't say anything i always
forget when i'm like doing some sort of
prop thing and then i like i'll just be
out in a [ __ ] cheerleading costume
yeah chris we love you thank you we hope
you'll come back one day 100
and spend we like to call ourselves
rotten sperm because we all had really
old dads when we were conceived actually
you'd like this fact yeah my dad is
about seven years older than anne frank
wow older than anna you thought you
liked world war two he liked world war
one so how old is your father
he's dead but he would have been a
hundred whoa
that's very very very interesting
wow i like that you know i just learned
that the last
person
whose father fought in the civil war in
1861 1865 just died like six months ago
there was somebody guy who fought in
civil war he had his child when he was
80. and then that man lived to like 99
and just died recently so it's like but
his a man who was walking around his
actual direct father was a civil war
this is why i think that i have really
bad genetics is because i'm actually an
older proto an older prototype than you
and you because yeah it's like i skipped
i'm from a generation we cut you open
it's warmer the whole way
no it's true i think i'm a boomer inside
that's why i have a heart condition i
have like weird autoimmune stuff because
my [ __ ] just hasn't evolved to your
level so healthy i just like cannot
believe i know it's like so hard that's
what pisses me off she [ __ ]
spearfishes and [ __ ] she's like oh my
god but i have like frail frailties
about me that really pisses me off and
that's why i don't i don't recommend
having old daddies so you're good i'm
glad you got your comments especially
you feel healthy you're not healthy
you're fine i'm i'm going to have to
meet with an old dad no matter what yeah
but not in his 60s i made it young zaddy
oh yeah
and all my sperm went in it wasn't like
oh a pull out and then it was like it
wasn't both my children are not like
pre-com children it's like full load
yeah kids so that's positive
that's why i think they're so you know
like i just gave it one game
yeah
yeah i left i gave you everything in the
morning it's like in that third eye
blind someone like
when they fell asleep inside you or
whatever when i fell asleep inside i was
like and did you wake up inside me still
get it out get it out guys thank you for
tuning in please like and subscribe this
to this video because our dads are old
we need them
we don't have financial support from
daddy and let us know who should be our
surrogates
yes comment what do you think like who
should be who should we get as our
surrogates maybe we should all get the
same person all right we'll see you guys
next week
[Music]
you